hey 42 here in 1928 archaeologist
giuliotello was poking around in the
deserts of peru searching for long-lost
treasures
when he unearthed what appeared to be a
burial ground containing hundreds of
ancient bones
the burial site belongs to the paracas
people an ancient culture that thrived
in the area almost 3 000 years before
tello had only recently discovered
evidence that the parakas people existed
so he was still in the process of quite
literally piecing together the mysteries
of this long-forgotten civilization
and contained within this burial pit was
the biggest mystery of them all
as expected it was full of what appeared
to be human remains
but there was something off about them
the ancient skeletons looked much like
the many thousands of others found by
archaeologists all over the world for
hundreds of years
except for one thing
the skulls
you don't have to be a medical student
to know roughly what a human head looks
like when you take all the meat off
but these specimens were nothing like
any skulls telo or anyone else for that
matter had ever seen before
they were impossibly elongated
looking more like something you'd find
in a modern sci-fi film than an ancient
grave
their strange appearance gave rise to
many controversial theories some have
speculated that the skulls belonged to a
previously undiscovered super
intelligent subspecies of human
others believe the skulls are of
extraterrestrial origin belonging to
aliens who first visited earth many
millennia ago to impart their wisdom on
ancient tribes and advanced the
development of human civilization
interestingly enough the parakas did
indeed possess many technologies and
insights
that seem to suggest an overworldly
helping hand they developed
sophisticated irrigation systems that
made agriculture possible in the baking
peruvian desert
they were also responsible for some of
the most intricate textile designs known
to the ancient world and they had an
incredibly advanced knowledge of
medicine even performing primitive forms
of brain surgery
these so-called alien skulls haven't
just been found in peru either since
telo's discovery similar skulls have
been unearthed in asia africa the
americas and many places in europe with
some of them up to 12 000 years old
in fact evidence of ancient
civilizations with elongated heads
stretches back so far
it predates written history
the earliest written mention comes in
the form of a poem by the greek poet
hesiod
written somewhere between 750 and 650 bc
the poem mentions a society of people
known as the macrocephali literally
meaning the big headed ones
so who exactly were these so-called big
heads could they really have been an
ancient society of globe-trotting aliens
who've been visiting earth throughout
the ages to give us pinheaded humans a
nudge on some of the trickier problems
in medicine agriculture and art or were
they an ancient subspecies of
big-brained humans have since died out
and all but disappeared from the history
books could it be that the critically
panned film coneheads was actually based
on a true story
okay so you're probably not going to be
surprised to hear that there's a
perfectly good albeit quite strange
explanation
for how tello's ancient skulls came to
resemble an h.r geiger painting sadly it
doesn't involve aliens but it's
interesting nonetheless
you see these unusual heads were created
for a process known as artificial
cranial deformation
which uses various binding and
compression techniques to deliberately
change the shape of the human skull as
you'll already know if you're a parent
have young nieces and nephews or just
happen to like prodding newborns in the
head
when babies are born their skull isn't
one solid mass like an adult's instead
it's made up of several plates with gaps
in between called fontanelles
these unfused bones make a baby's skull
relatively malleable
something that comes in particularly
handy as a child passes through that
most ancient torture device sometimes
known as the human birth canal
malleability also helps a child's skull
to expand as the brain within it grows
by the way the word fontanel is derived
from the french word fontaine
meaning a natural spring or source of
water
it's a fitting name really much like
natural springs babies also release vast
quantities of liquid
best not to drink it though anyway the
malleability of a baby's skull means it
can be reshaped a property cultures all
over the world have taken advantage of
throughout history
some bound the head with cloth others
strapped the child into a modified
cradle board that literally pressed the
head into the desired shape
whilst the methods varied the timing
didn't
cranial deformation processes usually
started around a month after birth
continuing for a period of around six
months but sometimes for years
once the bones in the skull had fused
the process was complete and the skull
retained its new shape
permanently
now before i go any further i should
probably include a disclaimer
please don't try and create your own
pointy skulls out of any children or
younger siblings that happen to be lying
around at home
growing up's hard enough these days
without having to worry about explaining
why you have a giant cone head
plus finding cats that would fit would
be a nightmare
so why the hell would anyone go to all
of this trouble to give their child a
pointy bones
i mean there are easier ways to stand
out from the crowd a brightly coloured
t-shirt for example or a particularly
daring pair of socks
the most common reason for this unusual
practice was to demonstrate social
status
in many cultures head binding was
reserved only for those in position of
power a person with an elongated head
was instantly recognizable as someone of
great importance as opposed to all the
peasants with their boring regular
shaped heads
some societies also believe that
elongating their head will cause the
brain to function better
though to date there's no evidence to
suggest the practice had any positive or
negative effects on brain function
as well as status many ancient cultures
found elongated skulls to be attractive
and the perfectly conical head was seen
as a symbol of genuine beauty
that might seem odd to us contemporary
minded types but concepts of beauty have
of course changed significantly all
throughout history
in japan purposely blackened teeth were
once considered incredibly attractive
in ancient greece a woman with a big
bushy monobrow would never fail to get a
man's heart racing
and in china the bone-crushing practice
of foot binding was a must if you're
going to bag yourself a fella
nobody knows for certain why some
ancient civilizations came to believe
that
when it came to heads bigger was better
some historians have suggested the
practice might have originated as a
desire to imitate the skull of a jaguar
which would have been a much feared and
respected animal for many ancient jungle
dwelling cultures
others believe it stemmed from wanting
to appear godlike the maya maze god for
example supported a lovely pointy head
that resembles the parakas skulls
another theory is that the practice
originated in some cultures as an
attempt to appear like those
original social influences
the ancient egyptians
although most historians dismissed the
idea that artificial cranial deformation
was performed in egypt some mummified
remains have shown evidence of elongated
skulls that are thought to have been
caused by a naturally occurring
condition called macrocephaly
the ancient egyptian civilization was of
course hugely influential
so it isn't implosable to think that a
well-known pharaoh with an oversized
noggin might have given rise to the idea
that big heads equal power status beauty
and majesty
and of course ancient egyptians are
often depicted as having elongated heads
in murals and sculptures
even though that's forced to have been a
stylistic exaggeration it could still
have sparked the idea that a big long
head was their season's must-have
accessory
of course today the thought of squashing
a baby's head until it resembles a
traffic cone
sounds somewhat questionable
but apparently not everyone would agree
because it turns out artificial cranial
deformation
is still carried out in parts of the
world to this day
including in vanuatu and the democratic
republic of congo
it was also carried out across europe
right up until the 20th century
whether it's a king wearing a crown a
football fan donning his team's shirt or
that dodgy geezer down the pub with the
fake rolex we humans have always looked
for ways to display our identity and
status through our appearance
sometimes that extends to modifying
ourselves physically with piercings and
tattoos or botox and plastic surgery
artificial cranial deformation may be a
bit more extreme than jamming a steel
rod through your tongue or inflating
various parts of your body with silicon
but you could argue it's all a similar
brand of crazy
thanks for watching